so I made a new short film yay well done
charlie lots of people said nice things
about it thank you very much to you
folks but there are also a fair amount
of people who said some less than nice
things about it and what the odds now
all I want to do is talk about dealing
with criticism first thing you need to
get in your head when it comes to taking
criticism
is to remember that it is not inherently
a bad thing try if you can to be
thankful that anybody is bothering to
criticize you at all because that is so
much better than someone looking at some
of you you've made and being like
alright that's not not even really a
reaction if someone's criticizing you
what it means is that they are paying
attention to what you've made they are
engaging with it and they're taking it
seriously and those are not bad things
the problem really just comes in that
that isn't how it feels especially if
you've been working on something for a
long time because I think that in my
experience the longer I've been working
on a project the more that project feels
like a reflection of me personally what
I like to do is to try and create as
much distance as I possibly can between
myself and the thing that I have made
because if that distance isn't there
you're gonna look at criticism and
you're gonna take it personally and
really the simplest way you can create
that distance is you just have to wait
you just have to resist looking at those
YouTube comments and then eventually
that distance will just create itself
the next step for me once I've created
that distance is that I like to read the
negative criticism and maybe this sounds
weird but personally as much as I love
people telling me that what I've done is
great
who doesn't feels lovely I just kind of
think that oftentimes the negative stuff
is just more useful it's not all gonna
be useful obviously a lot of it will be
people just being dicks because that's
what people are like they like to tear
stuff apart because it makes them feel
good naturally some of it is gonna be
like really well thought out really well
meaning it will make perfect sense but
you just won't agree with it it's just
not your taste that's completely fine
but then there's the stuff and it's
always there it's always in there
somewhere
you'll just look at it and you'll be
like you know what if I done that yes it
would have been better okay oh well what
is the lesson I can take from this to
apply to the next thing I do now just as
important as knowing how to take
criticism of course is knowing how to
dish it out as well and the number one
rule that I try and stick to is don't be
a dick he just
have to try and remember that all the
time there's a person behind that thing
that you just experienced who might not
be able to distance themselves from that
thing that they made and especially if
you leave in a comment on the internet
they will likely see it they'll take it
personally and they'll feel bad and you
won't have helped anyone I just see it
so often where I let someone is trying
to give good advice to someone else but
they're just not going about it the
right way and to me it's and now just to
like riding down the advice on a piece
of paper putting it in a clenched fist
and punching the person that they're
trying to advise in the face they can
very well be like I had the advice it
was right there it's good I it was right
there in front of you but all they're
gonna think is you punched me in the
face your pot I don't like you and
honestly learning how to hand someone
that advice isn't that hard all you need
to do is tell them what you liked about
what they made and tell them what you
think could be improved that's it if you
if all you do is tell them what you
hated they're not gonna listen to you so
we've all of that hopefully now you'll
think I'm being genuine when I say thank
you so much for watching my film thank
you for all of the positive comments
thank you for all of the negative
comments unless of course you're just
being a dick and let's hope the next
film is better that I learned some stuff
or else what's the point
bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
and in a ton of events that has
surprised the world Charlie put a link
to his short film at the end of this
video I hope you watch it if you haven't
already but if you don't it's ultimately
not gonna be a problem
and now it's gone you missed your chance
typical